I sorry to interrupt but um I think Ages  were irrelevant I mean there's there's a  limit to what I would go down to  obviously 25 is the lowest I will go  um but I think you could be this is from  a woman's point of view to men you could  be missing out from a really great woman  just because you put these restrictions  on ages and it's not all about you know  it's popping out babies it might be you  might find the woman the love of your  life or any they could be any age you  don't have to be popping Bay views out  but you could miss out for for amazing  long you know lifelong partner with all  your restrictions that's just my  personal point of view